par dell voici donc le parcours du
combattant du sieur jean jacques decour
que voici
al kanz si on ne peut pas être traitée
de charlot lorsqu'on est festive à lille
pour connaître les passages obligés côté
cinoche c'est simple le pij et c'est le
palais communément appelé le bancaire
c'est là que les cinéphiles 'prison seul
problème l'accréditation valoir un film
hier je fais très fort parce que j'avais
un billet mais j'avais pas ma carte
d'accréditation déjà passé en examen ces
pratiques 1 mais sinon il ya franchement
et sincèrement il ya au moins sept
barrages à l'heure du déjeuner les 3000
journalistes les producteurs les
attachés de presse les stars se
retrouvent sur la plage mais attention
pour être dans le coup il faut choisir
les endroits branchés
depuis quelques années le must c'est la
sportive ici on roule des mécaniques
oui mais c'est la plage on est sûr de
retrouver quelques potes on a perdu en
route s'ils sont importants vos amis
vous pourrez les retrouver dans les
palaces de la croisette et notamment au
carlton point de ralliement des
producteurs américains une institution
assiégée par les badauds raf vallone
résume pour l'apéritif les festivaliers
sont un peu perdus depuis que le goût
marqué jouxtait le vieux palais a été
détruite
et oui ça fait comme un trou c'est vrai
que c'est un lieu où on se dit quand on
traîne un peu on sait pas quoi faire on
y tient à l'heure on va aller au bout va
on va rencontrer des
des copains désormais c'est le bar du
majestic est le point de ralliement
après les séances du soir mais attention
là comme ailleurs il faut montrer patte
blanche ou signes extérieurs de richesse
c'est ce qu'il me disait il hier oui en
tout ça sans que cela une culture du
cinéma haïti et c'est vrai alors pour
moi qui suis un petit tailleur
conclusion pour s'éclater à cannes
il vaut mieux être riche et bien portant
que pauvre et malade et vous